et c'est la fin de cette séance de
questions au gouvernement on refait les
cadres on refait les questions au
Gouvernement tout de suite sur LCP on va
revenir sur les temps forts de cette
séance toujours ici en direct de
l'Assemblée nationale au cœur de cette
assemblée dans cette salle des pas
perdus qui est tout près de l'émission
où vient de se tenir donc cette séance
vous allez retrouver dans cette émission
elles a mandingava et Marco pommier qui
se trouve celle des quatre colonnes
ainsi que Clément Méric qui lui est cour
d'honneur c'est à dire à entrer
principal du Palais Bourbon il aura des
la ministre à son micro dans quelques
instants dès qu'ils auront quitté
l'hémicycle de l'Assemblée et avec moi
en plateau pour débat de ces questions
François Cormier bouligeon bonjour
bonjour à vous bonjour bonjour je suis
d'être avec nous vous êtes député
renaissance du Cher et Paul Vanier
bonjour vous êtes député la France
insoumise du Val d'Oise on retrouve tout
de suite Marco pommier parce que Marco
vous avez regardé cette séance depuis
les tribunes et vous vous retenez
particulièrement un échange entre la
première ministre et le député
Renaissance Antoine Armand c'est dans sa
circonscription qui a eu lieu le drame
d'Annecy oui Brigitte et c'est donc non
sans émotion qu'il est revenu sur le
drame l'occasion d'une standing ovation
dans l'hémicycle en hommage aux victimes
puis dans un propos plus politique il a
dénoncé les mensonges et les parades des
récupérateurs sordides et des
opportunistes de la haine une
intervention qui a piqué au vif le
rassemblement national qui lui a répondu
que c'était la majorité qui faisait de
la récupération dans sa réponse
Elisabeth borne a enfoncé le clou en
appelant à ne pas récupérer des drames
épouvantables une intervention que
Marine Le Pen a jugé honteuse et minable
c'est ce qu'elle a dit à la première
ministre dans un échange de regard avec
elle
merci Marco pommier on va revenir sur
les questions au Gouvernement plusieurs
questions des députés sur la lutte
contre les déserts médicaux alors qu'une
proposition loi du groupe horizon portée
par Frédéric valthou est actuellement en
débat dans l'hémicycle de l'Assemblée
nationale cette Agnès Firmin le Bodo qui
a répondu à la place de François Braun
qui est en déplacement aujourd'hui aux
côtés du président et donc ministre
déléguée à la santé on la retrouve tout
de suite aux côtés de Marco pommier
est-ce qu'elle est évidemment mes
croûtes Clément mairie que pardon
Clément est-ce que Firmin Agnès Firmin
le Bodo souhaite effectivement réguler
l'installation des médecins parce que
c'est ça qui est au cœur aujourd'hui des
oppositions de la majorité
oui c'est ce qui va être au coeur des
débats qui vont reprendre sur cette
proposition de loi Valtou qui vise à
lutter contre les déserts médicaux en
fait ça fait l'objet d'un amendement
porté par le socialisme Guillaume
Garraud mais qu'au signé par plus de 200
députés de tous les groupes politiques y
compris de la majorité et on vous a
entendu madame la ministre de cette
séance de questions au Gouvernement vous
opposez à toute idée de régulation de
l'installation des médecins libéraux
pour rééquilibrer un petit peu si l'on
peut dire les effectifs entre les
territoires sous dotés et ceux qui le
sont un petit peu moins même si la
pénurie est partout on vous a entendu
là-dessus vous dites c'est une fausse
bonne idée ça ne fonctionne pas comment
est-ce qu'on peut dire que ça ne
fonctionne pas alors qu'on n'a pas
encore expérimenté la mesure tout
d'abord ça ne fonctionne pas dans les
pays qui ne l'ont déjà expérimenté
certains pays européens notamment
l'Allemagne l'ont fait et sont revenus
dessus d'autre part nous voyons bien que
ceux qui étaient aux manettes il y a
quelques années Guillaume Garo lorsqu'il
était au gouvernement aurait pu le faire
ça n'a jamais été fait par aucun des
gouvernements en place nous nous savons
que cette mesure ne fonctionne pas il
n'y a aucun territoire dans lequel il y
aurait trop de médecins d'ailleurs à la
question posée au parlementaire est-ce
que vous avez trop de médecins dans
votre territoire aucun ne réponds oui au
contraire il faut apporter comme nous
l'avons dit pas de solution miracle
plein de mesures qui permettent pendant
ces années encore difficiles de pouvoir
apporter des réponses concrètes et
pragmatiques à nos concitoyens alors il
y a aucun territoire rétro de médecins
c'est vrai mais il y a quand même un
écart de 1 à 3 entre les territoires les
moins bien dotés et ceux qui le sont un
petit peu mieux et ce dispositif il
existe pour d'autres professions de
santé notamment pour les pharmaciens et
ça fonctionne du côté des pharmaciens
que je connais bien n'est pas tout à
fait la même problématique d'ailleurs
ceux qui prône la régulation change un
peu de j'allais dire de d'éléments de
langage on ne parle plus de médecin
généraliste on parle que de spécialistes
dans les propositions et les chiffres
donnés on ne parle que de spécialistes
pas de généraliste je le redis il n'y a
aucun territoire qui est trop de médecin
87% de la France est un désert médical
il nous faut travailler avec les
territoires avec les professionnels pour
apporter des réponses concrètes panneau
concitoyens pour apporter aussi un
accompagnement aux professionnels les
accompagner à travailler dans l'exercice
coordonné les accompagner à dégager du
temps médical c'est comme ça que nous
arriverons à franchir les 8 à dix années
encore très difficiles qui nous restent
parce que nous avons eu cette majorité a
eu le courage de supprimer le
numérologie c'était une des réponses à
aux difficultés que nous rencontrons
aujourd'hui un dernier sujet devrait
animer les débats lors de cette
proposition de loi valve tous et
l'obligation de garde
est-ce que le gouvernement souhaite
qu'elle soit étendue à tous les libéraux
on voit bien que là aussi entre
l'obligation et la responsabilité
collective que nous prenons que nous
prenons 96% du territoire et déjà
couvert par le système de garde nous
faisons confiance aux médecins pour
s'organiser entre eux il faut bien sûr
rétablir l'équilibre entre le public et
le privé aussi dans le système de garde
c'est ce qui nous permettra de
travailler sur j'allais dire une
répartition de la charge mais ce qu'a
proposé Frédéric Valtou à travers
l'article 1 c'est à dire le contrat
territor de santé nous permettra de
mettre ensemble tous les acteurs pour
répondre à ces enjeux à la fois de
permanence des soins et d'attractivité
des territoires merci beaucoup madame la
ministre je rappelle que les débats sur
cette proposition de loi tout vont
reprendre dans l'après-midi dans
l'émission merci Clément Méric Paul
Vanier vous venez d'entendre la ministre
Agnès Firmin le Baudot ministre délégué
à la santé j'imagine que vous allez vous
voter cet amendement transpartisan porté
par Guillaume Garraud qui vise à réguler
donc l'installation des médecins quand
on entend Agnes Firmin le Baudot elle
vit ça va créer une pénurie de médecins
alors que déjà on manque de médecins
est-ce que vous entendez cet argument
non je ne l'entends pas c'est vrai qu'il
y a une pénurie de médecins elle est
liée à ce numerus clos jusqu'à longtemps
existé elle est lié aussi au fait que
les études de médecine sont les plus les
plus les plus socialement sélectives de
notre pays il y a des étudiants issus
des catégories populaires qui ne peuvent
pas s'engager dans ces études longues et
d'ailleurs il y a aussi des amendements
qui visent à démocratiser l'accès aux
études de médecine donc bien sûr il faut
agir de ce côté là mais je faut savoir
que l'État doit intervenir et au fond
passe à une logique de marché de laisser
faire il faut une logique planificatrice
il faut non pas retirer des médecins là
où il y en a personne ne le propose ils
seront remplacés dans le cadre de
l'amendement qui est proposé et en effet
soutenu par 200 députés mais il faut
pousser à conduire à l'installation de
nouveaux médecins dans les déserts
médicaux et certes la France manque de
médecin mais pardon mais j'ai encore
regardé tout à l'heure sur doctolib dans
ma circonscription Argenteuil vous
n'avez pas la possibilité aujourd'hui
d'avoir un rendez-vous en gynécologie
par exemple dans le 16e arrondissement
vous en avez un dès demain donc il y a
bien des inégalités territoriales qui
sont très fortes et il faut il faut agir
pour les compenser c'est le sens de
cette amendement je voudrais ajouter
quelque chose du point de vue de la
méthode on a un travail transpartisan
200 parlementaire issu de tous les
groupes en dehors du groupe rassemblant
national on a une trentaine de meeting
qui se sont tenus partout dans le pays
ces derniers mois est-ce que le
gouvernement cette fois-ci va entendre
le Parlement entendre son travail
constater son travail entendre son
aspiration à être utile
ou est-ce qu'il va encore une fois être
dans une posture autoritaire et dire
circuler il y a rien à voir et empêcher
l'Assemblée nationale de faire son
travail alors on a plutôt compris que le
gouvernement en tout cas y était opposé
François Cormier bouligeon il y a des
députés de la majorité qui sont
favorables à cette amendement quel est
votre position à vous d'abord moi je
voudrais dire plusieurs choses un anti
macronisme ne fait pas une politique et
ça vaut encore sur la lutte contre les
déserts médicaux je veux le dire
pourquoi parce que je suis d'accord avec
mon collègue qui vient de s'exprimer le
problème que nous rencontrons il est dû
à plus de 40 années de numerus clausus
qu'aucun des gouvernements précédents
n'a voulu arrêter nous nous avons stoppé
le numerus clausus nous avons créé le
numerus à Perthus et par exemple dans ma
région en région Centre Val de Loire
nous allons passer de 200 étudiants en
médecine formés chaque année qui passe
en deuxième année à plus de 500 en 2025
donc l'effort l'État prend ses
responsabilités l'effort est fait pour
former davantage de médecins le problème
c'est que ça produira ses effets dans 10
ans entre 5 et 10 ans parce que nous
avons commencé à augmenter le nombre
d'étudiants formés 2019 ça ne règle pas
le problème une sensibilité qui est un
peu différente de celle du gouvernement
parce que je crois que autant il faut
respecter les médecins parce
qu'aujourd'hui c'est eux qui prennent la
vague et qui assument le travail à
longueur de journée j'étais hier à
Aubigny-sur-Nère dans un cabinet médical
et la médecin m'expliquait qu'elle
travaille 5 jours et demi par semaine
plus les gardes le soir plus les gardes
la nuit donc l'effort ne peut pas porter
davantage sur eux qui d'ailleurs
essayent de s'organiser au mieux mais
donc nous nous devons assurer à la fois
l'égalité traitement des médecins mais
surtout l'égalité des patients devant
l'accès aux soins et moi je suis
favorable à ce qu'on reconnaisse qu'il y
a des territoires qui sont gravement
sous dotés en médecins et que dans ces
territoires les médecins soient
encouragés à s'installer non pas par une
prime de 50000 euros parce que je crois
pas que ça produit ses effets vraiment
favorables mais par un
surconventionnement et donc moi je suis
favor j'ai déposé un amendement en ce
sens dans cette proposition de loi pour
que les honoraires soient augmentés pour
les médecins qui vont s'installer dans
les territoires gravement sous dotés et
qu'il soit remboursé à 100% et que à
l'inverse ce qui iraient s'installer
dans les zones surdentées ne soient plus
remboursé qu'ils passent en secteur 3
donc c'est une forme de régulation mais
par l'incitation c'est ça par
l'incitation et non pas par la
coercition parce que je crois que nous
devons respecter les médecins qui
portent le fardeau des déserts médicaux
en premier c'est eux qui sont en
première ligne nous l'avons vu pendant
le covid nous les avons salués nous
devons continuer à les soutenir parce
que c'est grâce à eux que le système ne
rend pas aujourd'hui mais nous devons
être fortement incitatif oui Paul
Valérien
je crois que celle-ci n'est pas la bonne
parce qu'au fond elle consiste à attirer
des médecins dans des déserts médicaux
en leur promettant une rémunération
supplémentaire pour résumer bref il
s'agit de les faire travailler davantage
pour gagner davantage mais on sait
qu'aujourd'hui beaucoup de jeunes mais
mieux rémunéré pour une consultation
peut-être mais on sait que dans ces
déserts la demande la patienter elle est
très nombreuse et elle a besoin
d'accéder à des médecins et donc il va y
avoir beaucoup de passion on sait qu'il
y a beaucoup de passions pour ces
médecins qui sont situés en dans des
déserts médicaux nous ce que l'on
constate aujourd'hui c'est les jeunes
médecins de quoi est-ce qu'ils ont envie
de quoi est-ce qu'ils ont besoin ils
veulent plus s'user 60 heures 70 heures
80 heures par semaine au travail ils
veulent une vie de famille ils veulent
pouvoir faire autre chose ils
recherchent un autre statut et dans les
amendements transpartisans qui sont
proposés aujourd'hui il y a notamment la
proposition de créer des centres de
santé avec des médecins salariés par la
Sécurité Sociale et donc un temps
maîtrisé dans la semaine des
travailleurs en équipe avec aussi du
personnel pour assister les médecins et
nous pensons que par ce type
d'incitation de nouvelles formes de
travail qui sont voilà qui apportent
aussi aux médecins l'avantage de temps
personnel c'est là que nous pouvons
aussi apporter une réponse
au médecin ce que propose le
gouvernement le fait d'interdire
l'intérim pour les jeunes médecins qui
arrivent sur le marché du travail ou
encore
d'autres propositions de ce texte de loi
ça ne vous semble pas aller dans le bon
sens quand on voit les cliniques privées
qui seraient mobilisées pour les
urgences tout ça ça peut décharger quand
même les médecins non vous ne croyez pas
que ça peut répondre aux problèmes je
crois pas je crois que pour le midi il
est profond il appelle à changer de
logique je le redis à cette logique au
fond de l'ordre libéral à passer une
logique planificatrice il faut que
l'État prenne en charge assume sa
responsabilité cette proposition de loi
pour l'instant elle est l'occasion pour
nous de faire des propositions elle
n'est pas convaincante à cette étape
donc nous verrons si le travail des
parlementaires encore une fois est
reconnu et peut être traduit dans la loi
à l'issue du vote des amendements des
médecins salariés comme le propose c'est
une idée je suis très surpris par la
réaction de mon collègue pour deux
raisons la première raison c'est que moi
je suis fidèle à au créateur de
l'assurance maladie à la à la
philosophie des créateurs de l'assurance
maladie parce que l'assurance maladie
c'est le fruit de nos cotisations à tous
et donc et elle doit servir le budget de
l'assurance maladie doit servir
exactement
et donc cet argent-là doit servir à
financer l'égalité des passions devant
l'accès aux soins et donc moi je dis que
le budget de l'assurance maladie doit
servir à financer des consultations là
où on en a besoin et non pas financer
l'installation de médecin qui sont en
situation enfin dans des zones première
chose exonération deuxième étonnement
deuxièmement moi mon collègue dit il
faut que les médecins travaillent moins
qu'ils puissent organiser que ça oui moi
je suis favorable à ça bien sûr mais il
ne se rend pas compte que dans les 5 ans
qui viennent à cause du virus clausus
qui a duré trop longtemps il y a un
véritable faille il y a un véritable
tsunami qui arrive face aux médecins et
aux patients et que donc ce qu'on doit
faire c'est au contraire permettre aux
médecins de travailler plus et d'aller
dans les zones soudainces et non pas
leur permettre de travailler moins parce
que sinon nous allons avoir des
centaines de milliers des millions de
patients sans médecins traitant or nous
nous devons mettre un médecin traitant
devant chaque patient c'est ça l'urgence
absolue alors des positions assez
tranchées on va retrouver Laurent Pagny
fou qui est aux côtés d'Elsa mondingue
Ava oui vous vous dites maintenant la
liberté d'installation c'est bien mais
il faut de la régulation puisque c'est
pas normal d'avoir autant de déserts
médicaux en France oui je dis que c'est
médicaux en France on le constate dans
nos territoires mais partout sur le
territoire national et pas seulement à
la ville dans les hôpitaux et également
dans les EHPAD que je connais bien on a
un énorme problème de vertication
médicale je sais que le sujet de la
régulation c'est un sujet qui crispe la
proposition de loi trans partisane que
j'ai cosinus elle propose une forme de
régulation positive et très modérée
puisqu'il s'agit de demander au médecin
de ne pas s'installer là où il y a trop
de médecins et on sait tous très bien
qu'il y a peu il y en a mais peu
territoires où il y a trop de médecins
et donc ce serait une mesure parmi tant
d'autres parce que bien sûr ça suffira
pas pour régler le problème de la
désertification médicale mais de faire
en sorte que médecin ne puisse pas
s'installer il y en a trop mais puisse
s'installer librement où il veut partout
ailleurs je trouve que c'est un premier
pas c'est un pas positif ça sera pas
encore une fois suffis
mais ça me semble justifier et
raisonnable dans le contexte actuel de
le faire Agnès Firmin le Baudot la
ministre était au micro de LCP il y a
quelques instants elle elle disait sa
risque de créer des pénuries de médecins
est-ce que vous pensez que et bien les
médecins diront non mais moi je fais pas
ce métier là si après je ne peux pas
choisir librement je m'installe mais je
n'y crois pas je crois que beaucoup
beaucoup de françaises de français
soient faire ce très beau métier et je
reconnais c'est une forme de contrainte
si on si on pouvait l'éviter ça serait
ça serait formidable pour autant la
situation est grave je pense que ça
devrait être une priorité nationale
c'est une mesure à mon sens assez légère
encore une fois on peut s'installer
partout où on veut en dehors des entre
danses il faut il faut éviter le mode de
régulation dit de manière trop simple
c'est une régulation modérée une
régulation positive donc non je suis pas
d'accord je pense pas que on fera en
sorte qui est si peu de jeunes qui a
envie de devenir médecin c'est un métier
magnifique il est toujours magnifique il
sera toujours demain et beaucoup
beaucoup souhaiteront encore faire ses
études médicales je le crois merci
beaucoup
trans partisans devrait être étudié
peut-être ce soir ou demain voilà
possible votre dans la soirée Laurent
pagnyfus député l'iode de l'Ariège on va
en venir à maintenant à l'attaque au
couteau qui a eu lieu à Annecy la
semaine dernière et qui a donné lieu à
une polémique sur l'immigration
déclenchée par l'extrême droite et la
droite cet après-midi c'est le député du
rassemblement national Yoann Gillet qui
est revenu sur cette question il a
interrogé le ministre de l'Intérieur sur
ces manquements je vous propose
d'écouter la réponse que lui a faite
Gérald Darmanin d'ailleurs les victimes
ne vous intéressent pas vous n'avez pas
un mot pour les enfants ce n'est pas un
mot pour les parents pendant cette
question d'actualité
si finalement l'histoire ne se déroule
pas comme l'imagine Madame Le Pen et
tout le rassemblement national et je
peux vous dire que c'est le dégoût qui
nous inspire quand vous parlez de ce
sujet deuxièmement monsieur le député
vous parlez de l'appel au peuple mais je
vous ferai remarquer que Madame Le Pen a
déjà été jugé sur son programme par deux
fois elle a été battu avec ce
présidentiel
et nous accordons un droit de réponse à
ONG qui est député rassemblement
national du Gard et qui se trouve au
micro de Marco pommiers salle des quatre
colonnes oui Brigitte Yohann gilet
Gérald Darmanin a eu des mots très durs
contre le rassemblement national il
estime que vous faites de la
récupération politique avec le drame
d'Annecy qu'est-ce que vous lui répondez
tout simplement fait de la communication
comme il s'est si bien le faire et comme
il le fait habituellement je lui ai posé
des questions concrètes je lui ai posé
des questions sur le droit d'asile sur
les auqtf qui ne sont pas exécutés je
lui ai posé la question sur le fait de
donner la parole au peuple à travers un
référendum sur l'immigration en
l'occurrence s'il n'a répondu à aucune
question vous savez Gérard Darmanin il
s'agit beaucoup il fait beaucoup de
communication et il préfère nous
agresser verbalement et tout et
n'importe quoi plutôt que de répondre
aux questions qui le dérange et vous
faites du coup un lien entre le drame
d'Annecy et l'immigration est-ce que
vous comprenez que cette manière de
faire peut donner l'impression à vos
opposants et bien que vous faites un
procès en fait à l'ensemble des migrants
c'est ce que disait par exemple
Clémentine Autain de la France insoumise
aujourd'hui non j'ai pas de
l'immigration en général et j'ai parlé
des progrès des problèmes d'insécurité
liés à l'immigration parce qu'ils sont
réelles on ne peut pas les nier les
Français les connaissent très bien ils
sont quotidiens les agressions les
meurtres parfois malheureusement tout ça
c'est quotidien vous faites un lien
immigré avec l'immigration à chaque fois
c'est pas 100% des personnes immigrées
et évidemment qui commettent des actes
en l'occurrence on sait que
malheureusement dans les agressions il y
a beaucoup de personnes d'origine
étrangère qui les commettent c'est un
fait on ne peut pas le nier il faut pas
fermer les yeux on n'est pas dans le
monde des bisounours et c'est sur cela
que j'interrogeais Gérard Darmanin et
l'actualité nous donne malheureusement
raison je préférerais avoir tort mais
l'actualité est-ce qu'elle est à savoir
que régulièrement des personnes sous-oc
qtf ou des personnes qui ont été
déboutés du droit d'asile et bien
commettent des infractions graves merci
beaucoup Yohann Gillet pour cette
réponse merci à vous Paul Vanier
Clémentine autant dit que ce propos
jettent un discrédit sur l'ensemble des
migrants est-ce que pour autant il ne
faut éviter ce problème de l'immigration
il faut pas parler de ce sujet pour vous
il y a deux choses bien sûr
l'immigration est un thème il faut le
traiter l'aborder pour la borne beaucoup
ces dernières années on a beaucoup
légiféré sur ce sujet
on traite pas le sujet de l'immigration
on sait pas le traiter on sait pas et on
pourrait développer d'ailleurs la
politique de la France insoumise mais je
crois que le sujet là il est celui de la
sécurité des Français face non pas un
migrant certes il avait beaucoup à dire
il était en situation régulière aussi
paradoxale que ça paraisse aussi
compliqué que ce soit son histoire elle
était en situation régulière sur les
territoires nationales mais il y a
peut-être un autre sujet que que la
politique de vautour du rassemblement
national d'ailleurs écarte mais dans
l'ombre c'est peut-être le sujet de la
psychiatrie ce manifestement et nous
verrons quelles sont les conclusions de
l'enquête mais manifestement était un
personnage troublé pour le dire comme
cela et on a aujourd'hui dans notre pays
un état de la psychiatrie qui est en
ruine on parlait tout à l'heure des
médecins mais savez-vous que 30% des
postes de psychiatrie sont vacants que
il manque 20 % des internes en
psychiatrie qu'en Île-de-France on
estime à 40 000 le nombre de personnes
sans logement cet homme était dans cette
situation qui sont en détresse
psychologique et qui qui mériteraient
qui nécessiterait un traitement pour eux
et pour la société
et vous me répondez sur la psychiatrie
parce que moi je cherche là à propos du
drame d'Annecy c'était autour de ça que
la question était posée à protéger les
Français a apporté des solutions
efficace
utile non pas être dans la démagogie
dans la stigmatisation dans la
xénophobie dans la haine de l'autre qui
est le fonds de commerce du
rassemblement national il y aura un
débat sur l'immigration si je comprends
bien à la rentrée le gouvernement le
prépare d'ailleurs dans une course à
l'échelle exactement vous dites cette
personne là était de manière régulière
effectivement en France elle avait le
droit d'asile en Suède il avait refuser
la nationalité elle avait du coup
demandé le droit d'asile en France
est-ce que vous trouvez cela normal
quand on est réfugié en Suède qu'on
puisse se promener dans d'autres pays de
l'Union européenne est-ce qu'il faut
poursuivre ça est-ce qu'on peut demander
le droit d'asile dans un autre pays
européen alors qu'on nous l'a refusé
ce point-là c'est la remise en cause au
fond de tout un tas de principes
fondamentaux qui sont propres à la
construction européenne comme la livre
circulation au sein de l'espace européen
vous voyez que on arrive à parfois à
d'autres sujets que ceux de
l'immigration quand on veut aborder ces
questions donc moi je cherche à
identifier les causes des problèmes
auxquels nous sommes confrontés et à ne
pas rentrer dans une forme de surenchère
qui ne répond en rien à la gravité du
problème qui nous a tous frappé des
froid le drame d'Annecy en l'occurrence
François Cormier boligeon hier
effectivement un texte sur l'immigration
qui est en préparation sans doute pour
la rentrée ou pour l'automne est-ce que
ce projet de loi immigration il pourrait
éviter qu'un drame comme Annecy se
reproduise ou c'est pas le c'est pas le
sujet non d'abord moi madame je veux
dire que la dignité sur ces sujets là
être primordial et moi je veux dire ma
fraternité vis-à-vis des victimes du
drame d'Annecy et de leur famille et ma
gratitude pour tous les citoyens qui
sont intervenus pour que ce drame ne
soit pas encore pire que ce qu'il n'a
été c'est extrêmement important ce que
je veux vous dire en seconde lieu c'est
que comme à chaque fois ils ont beau
mettre des cravates les députés du
rassemblement national n'ont pas changé
ils veulent faire de la récupération
nous l'avons vu et Madame Le Pen se
comporte en charognard de la vie
politique elle rôde elle survole le
malheur des Français elles sont repées
elle n'apporte aucune solution parce que
pardonnez-moi proposer un référendum sur
l'immigration c'est ne proposer aucune
solution parce qu'un référendum une
question par oui ou par non ne peut pas
régler ce sujet là moi sur ces sujets là
je dis une chose très simple la France
est un pays d'intégration c'est un pays
qui intègre des gens qui viennent d'un
peu partout dans le monde
n'existe pas mais par contre on ne doit
pas considérer la France comme un
supermarché dans lequel on pourrait
faire venir ses courses si l'on veut
devenir français il y a des procédures
mais il faut vouloir adhérer aux valeurs
de la République française liberté
égalité fraternité laïcité et si on est
sur ses principales alors on peut avoir
un débat qui doit se faire à l'Assemblée
nationale au Parlement parce que nous
sommes titulaires de la souveraineté
populaire et pas à travers un référendum
mais donc ce sont des usines que vous
êtes d'accord avec ce que vous venez
d'entendre
en quittant leur pays c'est-à-dire qu'on
part les systèmes de santé les droits
auxquels ils pourraient prétendre en
partant et donc choisissent leur pays de
destination en cette se faisant c'est à
mon avis non seulement c'était venir en
France c'est aussi s'intégrer en France
ça j'imagine que vous êtes d'accord
c'est nous nous sommes pour l'accueil
digne de tous ceux qui arrivent sur le
territoire national mais si si on veut
aller au fond du sujet de nous proposons
nous d'interroger les causes des
migrations partir c'est s'arracher à une
vie à un pays ça n'est jamais très
rarement un choix positif c'est sous la
contrainte parce que c'est la pauvreté
la misère parce que le changement
climatique vous pousse sur les routes de
l'exil parce que les guerres frappent
votre pays donc on peut pas accueillir
toute la misère du monde donc ça nous
nous proposons de permettre aux gens de
rester vivre chez eux parce qu'au fond
c'est à cela qu'ils aspirent mais pour
ça il faut changer de politique
commerciale en finir avec le
libre-échanger d'ailleurs tout à l'heure
on parlera du Mercosur dans les musiques
il faut lutter contre le réchauffement
climatique il faut une politique de paix
pour pacifier
méditerranéen il faut de l'aide au
développement vous voyez il faut traiter
les causes plutôt que de pourchasser des
gens qui sont épuisés qui sont et qu'il
faut aider vous prenez le le truc à
l'envers quoi
l'immigration sur le sujet de
l'immigration nous avons à la fois la
récupération du rassemblement national
et la naïveté de la France insoumise et
donc il faut regarder ce sujet là avec
sérieux encore une fois dire que la
France est un pays humaniste et qu'elle
accueille les demandeurs d'asile et
qu'elle intègre et qu'elle confère la
nationalité française à ceux qui veulent
respecter nos valeurs et nos principes
je le redis liberté égalité fraternité
laïcité nous devons aussi regarder la
question de l'immigration par rapport à
nos besoins par rapport à nos besoins
économiques nous devons d'abord avoir
une situation économique solide nous y
travaillons et nous tendons vers le
plein emploi ce qui permettra de pouvoir
accueillir des gens dans de bonnes
situations mais dire qu'on va pouvoir
accueillir tous les toutes les personnes
du monde parce qu'il y a des problèmes
climatiques c'est faux parce que nous
mettrions en danger à la fois notre
modèle social mais également notre
modèle démocratique donc moi je suis
pour avoir avec Renaissance une position
mesurée qui n'est ni celle du
rassemblement national ni celle de la
France insoumoute bien évidemment lieu à
l'automne prochain au moment du projet
de loi immigration et vous suivrez ça
bien sûr sur LCP on va tout de suite
retrouver Elsa mon Agava qui se trouve
au Marielle Durand et qui est
dessinatrice elle a croqué la séance du
jour oui une habituée puisque vous venez
très souvent lors de cette séance de
questions gouvernement regardez là ce
que vous avez voulu montrer c'est que ça
fuse dans tous les sens c'est ça en fait
ça a démarré tout de suite très fort
avec beaucoup d'invectives et en même
temps aussi des hommages notamment au
drame d'Annecy voilà qui a été plusieurs
fois cité donc on est entre les les
invictives et les hommages est-ce que
vous pouvez lire un petit peu voilà les
phrases que vous avez retenues
alors
il y en a justement une de juste autour
de d'Annecy nous sommes tous choqués par
le drame d'Annecy
voilà
pas un mot pour les victimes c'est ce
qu'elle dit Gérald Darmanin c'est ça
exactement donc voilà moi c'est vrai que
ça me touche en plus personnellement
par rapport à des histoires
voilà d'une personne qui a perdu son
mari au Bataclan et qui est à déménagé à
Annecy donc il y a une espèce de voilà
de de difficulté dans cette violence qui
poursuit la France depuis un certain
temps est-ce que vous montrez dans ce
croquis c'est qu'on est voilà entre
l'hommage et l'invective c'est difficile
d'avoir un moment d'union c'est ça
exactement alors on se lève on applaudit
on les gendarmes autant que les gens qui
sont intervenus mais voilà ça on évite
rattrapé par les
et les choses qui voilà la politique un
petit peu on le voit bien dans vos
dessins c'est vrai que beaucoup de
phrases beaucoup d'invectives dans
l'hémicycle merci beaucoup Marielle
Durand d'avoir partagé vos dessins merci
comme François Cormier vouligions et
Paul Vanier d'avoir accepté de venir
débattre sur le plateau de questions
d'actualité merci à Elsa monde un Gavin
à Marco pommier et à Clément mairie qui
manque accompagné tout au long de cette
émission merci à vous tous de nous avoir
suivis on se retrouve bien sûr mardi
prochain pour une nouvelle séance de
questions au Gouvernement sur LCP